Film Courage: How does someone really know
they’re a writer?
Maybe they just like the idea of being a writer
(the identity of it)?
Mark Sanderson, Screenwriter/Author: It’s
a good question (as always).
I’ve found with actors as well who I have
come in contact with that some people like
to play the role and others like to actually
do the work.
You can see because when it starts getting
difficult those who want to play the role
go “Hmm…this is hard.”
And then it becomes Well do you really want
to do this?
I always say writers write.
Writers are a special breed, you know what
I mean?
I don’t know if it’s hard to explain but
you are the one up at 2 0’clock in the morning
with passion and you can’t (to use a double
negative) not write.
It’s something that is in your blood, it’s
in your DNA to be a creative person like that.
So those people (like I said I used to work
in a restaurant as a waiter) and there were
some people who wanted to be actors and writers
as well.
“I’m working on that thing.”
And they never finished something.
That’s also another indication where you
can’t see it through where this person who
writes, yes there’s a lot of fear involved
because it might be crap.
You may not be able to level where you want
to be but you have to get through that to
get to the other side to master anything (martial
arts, whatever it is that you’re studying).
So a lot of the people wanted to be “acteurs”
like the brooding “Yeah, you know I’m
an actor.”
Wearing the leather jacket.
And you say “Well are you going on any auditions?”
“Well…no.”
“Are you taking classes?”
“You know, I have a good look.”
Okay well that will only get you so far so
I think some people may try writing “Oh
I think I’d like to write a screenplay.”
Which is fantastic.
It might not be maybe novel writing is better
suited or maybe both of them are not.
It takes a big commitment so I think you find
your way.
But for me since I was eleven I knew this
was kind of my calling making movies and things
when we were shooting films (short movies)
at eleven years old.
I knew because nothing would stray me from
that.
I think you either find out that it’s not
what you’re really passionate about or early
on you know it’s your passion early on and
nothing is going to stop you from it.
So I think that’s what designates a writer
for the long haul.
Film Courage: And the test for when things
are uncomfortable and it looks like it’s
not going to happen?
Mark: Yes, I always say failure is a test
to see how badly you want it.
And this life of a writer is filled with rejection,
failure and criticism and it’s not going
to go away even when you start working.
In fact I think the stakes are even higher
because then there is money involved and contracts
and pressure like I have to work under a deadline
and that was the first thing that was difficult
for me when I started working professionally
is that you’re supposed to be creative under
a deadline and how can you do that and some
when you’re working on your specs it’s
open-ended right?
You go Well I won’t work today or I’ll
go to the beach and when it becomes your job
it’s the job of any responsibility like
a job has to do.
You clock in and your clock in time might
be three in the afternoon as long as you get
those pages done at a certain time.
Question for the Viewers: Did you write today?